Okay.
[inaudible]
thanks for coming down.
We'll do a couple of songs and then we'll talk and then we'll do a couple more
songs and then we'll get the fuck outta here.
[inaudible]
sick
can vary.
Every
physician said
you as a SAS APP.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
Can
you exercise habits
back?
Roman fossilize hearts.
[inaudible]
yeah.
I want to say something so I can scroll.
Fuck out of there.
If I say something I said it against and I'll go with it.
I gotta stop saying fuck.
So the,
Oh shit.
This is bad.
All right.
Oh,
okay.
Uh,
we'll do another song now.
We'll do the [inaudible] right.
Every third thought.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
monster.
Nah,
what I have lost by forgiveness.
If you don't know the cops
romance.
Oh,
good.
My mother would be okay with it.
We'll do one more and then we'll,
uh,
we'll do a little chatting.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
What do you want to do or hot water.
Okay.
Good.
Bad
words.
Safety
sound.
God crosses,
you realize
shit storm
testify
in the test
and the test of our
choice.
I got a mark
washers
come on.
[inaudible]
I can't
see the light to get assault as God damn
could travel rates,
pass the pain
come hell or high water
water's
tissue.
You can build your life on promises,
promises to try it
out.
And I can work,
I can outwait your disdain to all this nonsense
come hell or high water
floods.
Hello?
Yeah.
Hello.
Hey,
uh,
so first off,
thanks for coming.
I appreciate it.
Um,
I'm going to,
I want to start with like some broader questions and then sort of work my way
down to more specific stuff about your work.
I like your strategy.
Thank you.
Um,
so first question is like in tech,
so we have this,
we have a huge,
one of our buzzwords is pivoting.
Okay.
Um,
and you know,
you've,
you've done academia,
you know,
you went to Princeton,
Yale,
all but dissertation,
you,
you know,
movies,
TV shows,
Expos,
Californication and now music.
So I guess my question for you is,
you seem to have to pivot
novels too.
I wanted to ask you more about that later as well.
Um,
I read Bucky fucking done.
You did.
Yeah,
I did.
Um,
so yeah,
you seem to
be giving compliments later on.
Um,
so you seem to have
compliments off the top,
but anyway,
go ahead.
Okay.
So you seem to have pivoted a lot successfully in your career.
So how are you able to do it?
What sort of challenges did you face?
Uh,
well,
I mean,
I just think,
uh,
it's not that I get bored so easily.
I just think I just have,
I've looked for other modes of expression to,
uh,
convey whatever it is.
I,
I've,
I feel I was put here to convey.
So just finding different ways of expressing whatever it is on my,
my mind or my heart at the time.
So,
um,
you know,
I started out as a writer on published and then I became an actor and then I
went back to being a writer,
actor,
and then I discovered music and started writing,
you know,
lyrically that way.
And uh,
also rediscovered myself as a prose writer at the same time.
So,
I don't know,
it wasn't really like intentional,
it's more just like,
I don't know how to,
how to phrase it in a way that makes total sense,
but it's just like looking for another,
a window out,
uh,
or window open,
to communicate something through that open window.
I've lost it now,
but,
um,
I think about your question.
Um,
you know,
had afforded me a lot of opportunity cause I had notoriety as an actor to be
given a listen as a,
as,
as a musician or a read as a,
as a novelist.
Uh,
at the same time though,
you know,
I'm open to attacks,
so just,
you know,
being a dill a ton.
So it's both.
Uh,
I get,
uh,
I get an opportunity to reach more people than I probably would if I didn't have
any kind of notoriety,
but also I don't get taken seriously.
Like,
what the fuck are you doing?
You know,
you just stay in your own lane.
Yeah.
Is Your,
uh,
is your Twitter,
um,
taglines still Dillard taught?
No,
but that's good.
It was when I used to actually involve myself in it.
Yeah.
When I first of all we do is still tight.
I really like that tagline.
Bring it back.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
so I guess my second like,
so I think from a lot of your writing,
like I said,
I read Bucky fucking dent.
I really enjoyed it.
You can talk more about it if you want it to is uh,
David's second novel.
It's set in.
So the main character lives in the Bronx.
Much of it is,
it's like all set in New York.
Yeah.
I'm in hell or high water.
A lot of your songs also reference New York and your first album.
So,
um,
you know,
what are your favorite New York bonds?
Um,
where can we find you on like a random Tuesday night?
So,
uh,
I grew up in New York,
so it's in me just as a reference,
you know,
it has all this feeling for me and,
and uh,
I,
I don't say that I love New York.
I'm not one of those guys.
Like,
I,
I kind of love,
hate it with a emphasis on hate a lot of the time.
So,
um,
I find myself just writing about it in a weird way.
As much as I always talk about leaving it,
uh,
just I'm,
I'm,
I feel like I'm destined to never leave it in some way.
Um,
even though I think I've been trying to leave it for most of my adult life.
So I think that's kind of the push pull with me in New York.
I mean,
I grew up not far from here.
I grew up,
I told you 11th street in second half of year and it's all,
it's all very different now.
But,
but you know,
this is my favorite neighborhood of New York.
The,
the East village is the,
and the,
and the West village.
Um,
to me that really has a lot of nostalgia because I used to hang out.
I did hang out here.
Um,
there was a movie theater where the equinoxes now,
which is just tells you everything you need to know about New York,
on Greenwich since and uh,
and 12th
I think it is.
Okay.
Um,
so I think I want to get a little more into your current album.
I know that some of your songs,
I think spiral was written by your bandmates yeah.
Marvel son was kind of a collaborative effort.
I assume you the rest is solo.
Do you prefer
really solo?
But the,
the other ones would have been songs that I,
I first wrote on my own and then brought to the guys and we worked on him.
So yeah,
I guess the inspiration would be solo and then,
you know,
the,
uh,
the actual execution of them would be more of a team effort.
I see.
Do you prefer like one over the other?
I'm just not good enough to really bring it home myself.
I mean,
I'm not,
uh,
I'm not like a skilled musician and,
I throw chords together and put words and melodies on those chords.
And then,
you know,
when we first started working,
I will introduce you to the guys when they come back up.
Um,
if they haven't left already,
I left.
Um,
you know,
it was like,
they were like,
oh,
this song needs a bridge.
And I'm like,
ah,
what's bridge?
So architectural question,
I didn't understand.
So,
so it's been a learning process for me,
collaborating with them,
I'm sure a learning process for them.
And I will say that,
uh,
one of the good things about working with somebody who has no education in that
particular field and just as feel is that I may I make mistakes that are
interesting.
Sometimes I make mistakes that are horrible sometimes,
but I also make mistakes that are interesting and that,
that might,
that might make sense here at Google.
I don't know how they tell you to be in the culture or whatever.
They feel fast.
I don't understand what that mean.
It means if you're on a bad road,
get off at quickly.
Yeah,
I guess like make mistakes but learn from them fast.
I used to always quote this backup thing was,
was fail again,
fail better.
I wonder if,
uh,
if,
if it's been ripped off by you guys.
Yeah.
Fast.
Alright.
Feel fast.
I'm going to ponder on that.
Um,
yeah.
So related to that,
um,
a little Birdie told me or some publication I read that,
you didn't pick up a guitar until like,
you didn't learn guitar until like three years or so before hell or high water.
Yeah.
Um,
is there a reason why,
like first of all,
I guess,
do you regret picking it up so late and was there a reason why you chose to,
you know,
self learn versus get a teacher or you know,
when you obviously have the resources right.
It did.
We just got to check in.
We can afford guitar lesson.
Good.
You guys want to take it over?
Um,
I,
uh,
well,
you know,
it's a good question cause I actually have an answer for it,
which is,
uh,
I didn't want any homework.
I mean,
I didn't want it to feel like I was doing it for anybody.
I just wanted to teach myself the chords and the songs that I wanted to play on
my own in my room by myself.
And nobody ever asked me to sing as he,
you know,
that first song was rough.
I have trouble,
you know,
I mean it's like my pitches learned.
So I,
nobody ever said,
you know,
David's got to be in the choir because we got to hear that voice saying,
so there I am.
There I am,
you know,
learning my chords and singing as best I can in my room.
And the last thing I wanted was to have to,
all my life I've been doing homework as you,
as you referenced,
I've been in school.
When I,
when I act,
I got to learn lines.
I got to show up prepared.
I have homework every day.
I didn't want homework.
I didn't want somebody to have to,
you know,
you did not practice David,
you did not do your scale.
So I just want it to be fun without any kind of pressure.
So this is the only time in my life it's ever been.
Everything I've ever done was for somebody else's appraisal.
So it makes no sense that I would actually bring out this music for other
people's appraisal at this point.
But that's,
that's where I'm at.
So you want to keep it as your own thing,
right?
Just you.
Well,
no,
obviously not.
Obviously not.
I,
I bring it out,
you know,
I,
at some point I started to feel like it was worthwhile and it was good and I
wanted to share it.
And it has a lot to do with the guy who just spoke Brad Davidson.
And he was really pushing me to,
you know,
get better and,
and,
and so this,
you know,
so the songs are worthwhile.
Um,
and so,
you know,
it was just me being pushed eventually.
And then it's just ironic that,
you know,
something that started out just for me,
uh,
you know,
ends up being something that I do in public.
Um,
I also,
I think in the Cambridge sort of,
um,
it's just,
I can never get all those guys to come to my house with all their stuff and set
up in my living room.
So I got to do it out here.
Um,
I think in the,
in the Cambridge performance set,
uh,
so David also performed in our Cambridge office.
You're joking that,
you know,
people used to tell you like,
don't sing.
Like,
you know,
they're told you like you weren't a senior and then you got a voice teacher.
And that's of reminded me of kind of the age old question of like talent versus
grit.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know.
I wanted to get your thoughts on that.
Like you're obviously a great singer.
No,
no,
but,
but I,
but I have a voice,
you know,
and,
uh,
and I get up there and I sing.
Um,
well I,
I,
you know,
um,
I can,
I'll make mistakes,
you know,
um,
pitchy like the Santa American idol,
you know,
pitchy,
but grit versus talent.
I think grit is a talent.
You know,
I played a lot of sports in my life and I've seen guys with tons of talent,
but no grit.
And you kind of tend to blame people with no grip,
uh,
in a way that you wouldn't blame somebody with no talent.
And I really do believe that grid is a talent.
I don't know if it's learned or if it's genetic,
but,
um,
it's one thing I've tried to teach my kids as a resiliency.
I guess that's another word for it,
is the ability to,
to keep at something when you suck or,
and that was one of the reasons why I took up guitar aside from wanting to
please myself in my room was I had young kids and I,
I was adamant that I would find something that I didn't know how to do.
And I wanted them to beat musicians,
not for their job,
but I just wanted them to have that opportunity in their lives.
And I thought,
well,
you know,
I'm always preaching at them that you got to keep working,
so I'm going to show them I'm going to work,
you know,
I'll try and get better at this thing that I'm not good at.
And you know,
lucky me,
they both play guitar.
My,
my son's actually a really good guitar player at this point,
so a way better than me.
So,
um,
you know,
when you start young there's a,
there's a real advantage,
but,
um,
there's jam together,
you know,
if I sneak in like,
like he,
he doesn't want it.
He doesn't,
he doesn't want me there,
you know?
But if I sneak in with a guitar,
you know,
if he's playing,
he'll heal me.
But he plays,
he,
he loves like the music that I grew up with.
He listens to like late 60,
70 students.
He's playing a wish you were here by pink Floyd and he's like a,
he's on a time warp or that I love and I hope he never gets out,
I guess.
So in this,
um,
big fan of grit,
I guess I'm a fan of talent as well.
Okay.
But a thesis.
Yeah.
I,
I'm all,
I'm all about the grip.
Okay.
Um,
so I guess in this album you,
um,
I know like one of the songs,
Jericho is a song kind of written to your father.
Do you have any songs that you particularly are hold close to your heart or
you're kind of,
yeah.
Agnostic?
Well,
I'm agnostic with a yearning for something greater.
Sure.
I think we all have to be joined with something greater than our selves or our
Egos.
But,
um,
I,
I think,
you know,
all the songs I was thinking like,
oh,
I'm at Google,
I'm going to say something really clever that all the songs are like,
and I don't know what writing code is,
but all the songs are like writing code.
Language is like writing code.
I don't know what writing code is.
Let me just emphasize that.
But the language is a code.
We think of languages,
something that's opaque and transparent to our thoughts,
but it's not,
it's an act.
It's an actual code and it's,
it's,
uh,
it's slippery and it's,
it's inexact.
And so when I write songs,
I love that fact.
When I,
when I speak,
I don't love that factor.
When I try and make my heart clear,
my mind clear to somebody,
then it's frustrating because words are always inadequate.
But in a song they can,
it can get much bigger than,
you know,
the code you're writing about something,
but it's coding for something else.
I,
it's not what code means.
I know I,
so forgive me,
but I just had that thought coming over here.
But what was the question?
Jericho's about my father coded.
Yeah.
A lot of my songs,
like half life is,
you know,
the code is,
you could say it's divorce,
you could say it's mid life.
You know,
there's many different ways into that song.
And I deliberately vague specifically vague enough to,
to make it both personal to me and hopefully universal to other folks.
So it's like as any artists,
you leave it up to the interpreter,
you put it out there.
Well,
yeah,
I mean I think any song,
I mean,
you know,
I,
I could,
I could sit you down and I could walk you through a song and tell you what I
thought I was writing.
And that will be interesting if you said,
well,
actually I thought that song was about this and hopefully what you're,
your interpretation wouldn't be about,
well,
something happened in David's life and he did this and he did that,
but it would be like to your life.
Um,
so yes,
there's something especially less about movies,
television and novels and more about music,
which to me is very much,
you give that to other people and you,
you'll let them kind of make it their own for them.
You know,
that's,
this song now belongs to you and you make it mean what you want.
I think more than the other art forms,
songs are really like that.
So before I ask this final question,
if you,
if anyone in the audience has Q and a questions,
you can start lining up and the two microphones on the side now.
No one's getting up.
Okay.
Um,
wow.
I think,
um,
you know,
a lot of us who work here,
you want it,
you guys want to ask me anything?
So a lot of us who,
you know,
I think people in general strive to keep improving,
right?
So,
and like you put out an album and now we have a second one.
You have three books are,
sorry,
you have two books out.
Now you have a one forthcoming miss subways in,
oh,
sorry,
a third one coming out in May,
miss subways.
Um,
how do you approach your work and just like continuing to
improve?
I think he's just improved by doing,
you know,
I think that's how I learned how to be an actor.
I'm,
and I was lucky enough to,
to get a job.
I started fairly late for,
I thought,
you know,
at 27,
27 ish,
I had gone to graduate school,
as you mentioned,
summer job.
Right.
Well,
and it turned into that.
Yeah.
So,
so I really,
uh,
was lucky in that one of the first jobs I got was,
was the x files and I got to go to,
I had to work every day for like 14 hours a day being an actor.
And after a couple of years of that,
I,
I learned,
you know,
but I didn't know.
I thought I knew,
I guess what's,
what's blissful is that if you think you're better than you are in the
beginning,
that's,
I don't know how you can teach that to somebody,
but it's like,
have more confidence than you should have.
And then you go forward and you try things and then eventually as you get actual
experience you realize,
oh no,
you actually sucked back then,
but that time has passed and now you're okay.
You're actually so you don't have to worry about it so much unless it's my case
when it plays in reruns and you get to watch how bad it was.
All right.
Uh,
we're going to open up for Q and.
A.
I guess we'll start here cause there's more people there and Hey David,
how are you?
I'm Sarah,
sir.
Hey,
uh,
so you're clearly a multi talented artist as we saw you perform today.
Curious to know which musicians dead or alive have inspired you to make your
music or any favorite songs.
Yeah.
Um,
well I mean
to say that I'm inspired would,
would be to say that I could actually,
you know,
do something in the vein of them on purpose.
I can't do that.
I'm in a more,
a more of an unconscious like songwriter.
Cause like I said,
I'm not schooled in that way.
So if I tried to write a Beatle song,
I couldn't do it.
But certainly I feel inspired by the Beatles or,
or petty or,
or Bowie or,
you know,
sly and the family stone.
And I do want to get a little more funky in my music.
You know,
I want,
I want a little more slack.
Go George Clinton.
That's a little too funky.
Atomic dog.
Yeah.
Some of them like that.
I mean,
I'm really sly and the family stone for me,
uh,
you know,
even like seventies,
like,
uh,
Ohio players,
you know,
stuff like that.
But,
you know,
I don't even know.
We got to talk about doing shit like that.
Ready?
Yeah,
we're ready.
A Fleetwood Mac is another band that I really liked the sound of,
uh,
you know,
the stones I love,
but I don't know how I'm influenced by them,
but you know,
you definitely have a petty,
petty,
petty welcome.
Thank you.
Hello.
Um,
I'm also a native New Yorker.
I appreciate what you said about loving it and wanting to leave it.
I'm actually leaving to move to La and I was wondering if you could give any
advice to a New Yorker moving tail.
I whom?
What to do
sunscreen.
I love La.
I got to say,
I think if people want to leave la too.
I Dunno.
Where are you going to move in la?
You don't know?
You don't know where?
I'm not sure.
Maybe Santa Monica.
Sure.
You've got your,
you're fine.
You know cinema.
I love Santa Monica.
Venice.
I love if you come from New York,
you kind of want to see the ocean I feel.
And then I always,
I always like to see the ocean.
So that's kind of where I've lived in La.
I feel like I like to see the end of the world,
the edge of the world.
I like to see the edge of the world.
I see no more people.
Just fish.
Hi David.
Thanks for coming.
My name's Tibi.
Um,
my question for you is I think fans of yours,
we all know you for your sense of humor.
And I think even back in the x files days,
we saw you inject humor into what could otherwise be like really dramatic
character.
And then you kind of finally got to explore that in California cation.
So my question is,
was starting out in such a serious character and kind of a serious world,
was that kind of,
um,
almost a struggle to be able to show that side of yourself or tap into it?
Um,
well,
it was more,
it was more like a PR perceptual thing for others because the,
the character was so well,
it was dry,
but you had to be paying attention if you wanted to think of Mulder was funny.
It was very easy to,
to,
to think of him as not funny at all.
So,
and it was important for me always to,
to inject that as you say,
into the show.
And it was always something,
you know,
even going back to the last time we did it this year,
it's just,
um,
the fighters always,
you know,
me wanting to make it funny and real and the studio saying,
but people are dead.
And to me that this was never a good enough argument,
you know?
Um,
to me the funny is the gold of it,
you know,
so,
uh,
so it was more,
but it was more when I was coming off the show just to,
uh,
people didn't perceive me that way.
No other people didn't perceive me that way.
I'm at,
it's just,
I don't look funny,
I think,
I dunno,
I don't look like I'm going to be funny or something.
So yeah,
I had a struggle with that a little line.
It was a,
it was also finding the right comedy for me.
I mean,
when I,
when I got off the x files is the first time it was really the hay day of like
a,
you know,
Ben,
Ben Stiller and,
and uh,
even going to like Jim Carrey,
Steve Corral will Farrell on these,
these,
this is a different kind of comedy than I do.
And,
um,
so I was kind of for Lauren about all that,
I was like,
Hey,
you know,
I can't,
I can't go against those guys doing that stuff.
I was looking for more like seventies style comedy in the movies.
So when I took Californication was really like,
oh,
that's kind of when I can do this,
you know,
articulate in that way and not knock a Manchild,
not like a boy,
like a a man in a man's world and whatever,
you know,
doing that stuff.
So I thought I could do that.
Definitely.
It was super hilarious.
Hi,
I'm Cory.
Thank you for coming in.
Yeah.
Um,
you've worked in a lot of different mediums,
TV,
film,
usually like writing.
Um,
and they all have really different ways of pulling in your creative process.
Which do you really prefer?
What do you think reflects your work as an artist,
collaborative work or kind of individual heads down in your room alone?
Work?
Well,
both.
I mean,
I think the novels represent my most selfish,
just me in a room,
you know,
I have an editor and he edits me,
but it's really just,
that's just coming from,
from me.
Um,
that's not collaborative.
it,
music is very collaborative with the band.
I need it.
Um,
film and television is by nature,
extremely collaborative.
And I love that I'm a good director.
Hires is like a good president,
hires people who are better than he is or she is at the things that he or she
doesn't do.
And we see what happens when
that doesn't happen.
Although it's,
it's almost an impossibility to think of somebody who is not better than our
current president at anything.
And yet he finds people that are less better at it than he is.
Interesting.
Um,
so that's what a director does.
So directors,
uh,
like the immune system of the film,
he like,
he keeps all the bad ideas out and let's all other,
it's other people play with our good ideas.
So I really enjoy it.
I do like to collaborate very much,
but there came a time when I wanted to sit down and just write in my own voice
and that's what the novel is kind of represented.
I'm sorry guys,
we don't have time for any more questions.
Um,
yell it out.
Well,
I'm Elmont why my mom,
David,
do you and your band have a name?
Chihuahuas?
I can't remember which was the hand that I modeled.
Oh yeah,
it was before this Bulova watch catalog.
Do you and your band hub
for one more song?
Yeah.
Cool.
You asked if
there was a song that was meaningful to me.
So actually the last song that we're going to do,
uh,
also involves my father.
Um,
it's called stranger in the sacred heart.
And this,
uh,
we were touring in Europe and we were in Paris and I went to this church called
the sacred heart,
which is in the neighborhood of the hotel.
I was staying at him.
I was told by the folks there that,
uh,
the people,
the custom there is to pray for others,
not to pray for yourself and actually to pray for the world.
Really?
Yeah.
Um,
not just Paris,
not just French people,
but actually the world.
And I thought I'd never heard that before and I really liked it.
So the song,
along with the fact that my father had died in Paris a few years earlier,
uh,
of came together.
Okay.
It's called stranger in the sacred heart.
Hmm.
[inaudible]
my father had a very hard two
days gone by about
just outside my door.
Uh,
say cred.
Everyone plays someone else's par.
Strangers,
strangers,
crack.
Juicy street's ass.
Uh,
say Greg,
everyone please.
Someone else's par
strangers.
Strangers,
say grill
and
Bellis
pins.
Soccer last mile
else.
Two strangers.
Stranger.